hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
continuing on the theme of old school
unboxings
I just recently unboxed a slow guy the
original iPod and today we're gonna be
unboxing the iPhone 3GS this is the
third gen iPhone in the series of
iPhones and here it is in all of its
sealed original package glory my one
main concern though is what's that I've
been kind of into unboxing the phones
that I never actually unboxed on YouTube
On June 19th 2009 was when this phone
was launched and I have this little
video of me in the Apple Store the David
it launched in San Francisco I'm a
little nervous though because I really
don't know what to expect is it gonna be
cracked is he gonna be shattered is this
actually going to have been opened up I
mean this was a long time ago the eBay
listing said that it was factory sealed
but do we believe it I don't know like
this looks to be a little little wear
and tear right there so the original iOS
on this little guy was 3.0 and he last
stopped supporting it February 21st 2014
and that was iOS version 6 1.6 his model
came in 8 16 and 32 even until fairly
recently 32 gigs is the least amount
that you were able to get in a current
iPhone and that was the most back then
crazy okay it really hurts to look at
this package knowing how long in his
state sealed and what a sweet sweet
moment it's gonna be 2009 let's do this
[Music]
they're so bad
Wow this is so old it's old and no one
has opened it I don't know why so if you
have the main selling points for the
upgrade was a video camera voice control
and a digital compass to be honest with
you I had to look it up because I didn't
remember is it gonna be broken I've
opened a lot of Apple products before
and this is not handiwork of an original
boxed unboxed iPhone I just want to tell
you they would never ever ever do this
this is all scuffed up these people are
liars Apple would have never done this
ever this is this is a sham this is a
sham like I just can't believe that
Apple would put something on like this
it doesn't like hardly even matches up
look and this it's like look at this
yeah that's something Apple would never
do so I think I got shy stirred like in
what was that that was rattling around
this seems to be all there though it was
sealed very well and I clearly don't
remember unboxing my 3GS I just no but
that's something that I don't think
Apple would have done and they usually
have perfectly applied plastics
everything is like to the tee I feel
cheated and lied to we've got our
original stickers though which is nice
it's still says 3GS so that's something
so here's our brochure it smells old
this looks like it has fingerprints on
it and they're not mine I don't know
what to think
anyway let's take a look at this
brochure if there's something that you
would like to read just hit pause and
then play again look at that
so cool
[Music]
okay well I'm gonna put this stuff all
back in here because well maybe I'll
sell to somebody else
hey this definitely hasn't been opened
because this is something it's very hard
to reproduce is this exact plastic it
has the Apple feel to it this one right
here what happened heat like this is me
this is what I thought I heard flying
around do you guys remember where this
was it's tiny little SIM card remover
I'm pretty sure used to be in here let's
just say that's something
listen responsibly drive safely read
safety information check local laws
before use interesting the memories are
flooding back plugging it in take a good
look okay so those smudges are mine but
basically this entire thing was pretty
flawless is it even goes if it doesn't
start up that's gonna be such a
disappointment I definitely see
something happening oh my god it's
starting it's starting so maybe we let
it charge a little bit and then I'll
come back and give you guys an update I
think this thing's been charging for a
while the back doesn't feel hot to the
touch but like it feels a little bit
warmer that is it previously like it's
not warm there was a lot of issues with
the 3GS of the back becoming a little
bit too warm where the battery is I
don't think I ever had that problem but
I do remember there were a bunch of
issues like thatch thankfully I didn't
have it no service yeah no kidding there
it is oh gosh look at that on lock it's
funny it's not even picking up my 5g
wireless signal I'm able to join Network
restore from iCloud set up as a new
phone and clearly I'm setting it up as a
new phone may take a few minutes to
create your new Apple ID okay so
apparently it's letting me create an
Apple ID so I guess it worked I'm gonna
not use iCloud
I'm pretty sure there's absolutely no
way that I'm gonna be able to make a
phone call because FaceTime FaceTime
audio calls wasn't a thing look at this
home button ah brings up your search
that oh my goodness my most recent apps
let's peep this old-school YouTube
button this was back in the day when
YouTube what is that oh my gosh it's not
like not even working like these are the
featured videos nothing is there it
doesn't even work search let's see if
search works doesn't work at all nothing
works here's the camera there's no front
facing camera photo stream okay I take a
picture of like this is how we used to
take selfies okay so just hope that it
was in focus wow it's so slow so it's
definitely a little bit of lag you guys
can see it's not as smooth as it is
currently because hey technology change
this is only a 3 megapixel camera which
is pretty crazy it still looks pretty
decent photos see oh my gosh it's so
slow I'm tapping and nothing's happening
there's the Apple Campus it took us
right there that's what the old school
maps look like do any of you guys
actually remember this phone just so if
you still have this phone I'm curious to
see what point in life here I started
getting iPhones loading the Apple store
I mean is anything even gonna happen oh
this new and no worthy well I haven't be
able to download these I know the Katy
Perry even had a music video out
wow this is great well let's see if we
can download an app would you like to
get your free copy of iBooks now I'm
okay thank you see if we can install
Spotify holy moley it's downloading wait
the Apple ID has not been used in the
iTunes Store iTunes let's see I feel
like I'm doing some sort of like
surgical procedure right now and I'm
just setting up an old iPhone I don't
never use iTunes anymore okay that's it
it should work it should work I think
it's gonna work this application
requires iOS 8.0 or later you must
update the iOS 8 it's a load and use
this application I know why don't you
Spotify on my old baby boy phone then
how am I even gonna do anything I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna be able to do
anything like who thought this was a
good idea me anyway well this is what
our calendar used to look like old
school calendar it's a useless device I
mean here's the weather I can use it to
see the weather I guess some people have
you know crazy collections of things and
this is something that I choose to
collect I guess that's really it I'm
gonna find a very very nice home for
this on my Apple shelf over there of old
iPhones and old gadgets I'm still trying
to find an old-school original iPhone I
mean I have one which is in pretty good
condition
but I haven't been able to start it up I
don't know what's wrong with it but I
really really really want to find one
that is in mint condition and it hasn't
been opened but they're very very hard
to find because most of the ones that I
found are not the original
first-generation ones the second gen and
some of the ones that are first gen are
like $20,000 and at that rate I might as
well buy myself a new car because that's
just absurd or maybe by the phone and
then put some freaking wheels on and say
here's the Apple car it's not let's do a
little comparison and show you guys what
this phone looks like compared to the
original iPhone to the new iPhone and to
one of the original iPods so you got a
3GS in comparison to the original
original iPhone they are pretty much the
same exact size
not pretty much they are button
locations very very similar 3.5
millimeter jack power button sim card
slots all the same the irony is that
this is a jet-black iPhone essentially
here we have the seven plus so if we
just kind of put these together and
they're gonna be smudgy I'm sorry here's
the iPhone 7 plus this is the newest
iPhone and this is a 3GS and basically
tap black so when they announced that at
something new which have like iPhone it
really wasn't new they've already done
it they come out with a jet white
ceramic iPhone let me tell you what I
will definitely be first in line for
that one
so here's the front those buttons are
very very similar they're still a circle
but that's about it
hopefully on the next version of the
iPhone or not the next or the next next
version if there's on iPhone 7s or if
there is a 7s or if it ends up being the
H or the 7s is just a small upgrade and
then the eight is actually a big upgrade
and those are all out at the same time
who knows rumor has it there won't be a
button which I would be totally fine
with something that's really cool on the
pixel phones which I've become quite a
huge fan of is they have the fingerprint
sensor on the back so if you're just
holding your phone and you go like that
you could unlock your phone iOS 6 1 is
now available for your iPhone that's the
latest version and it said I can't do
that I can't do that screenshot add
contact create new contact contact
justine so okay i set myself a message
it said it was delivered there it is
said today what about the emojis would
will Mochis look like there weren't
emojis back then all their little
squares the ones that don't work oh you
sweet baby so she use emojis back in the
day you used to have to do all kinds of
weird things download all these separate
apps Japanese keyboards and then hit
activate it was quite the process you
guys don't know how well you have it
unless you do know how well you have it
then you're well where so here they are
this is the family it's quite a strange
little soup tower I had a much more
nostalgic feel for this one because I
feel like as I was unboxing both of
these things I was kind of feeling the
same feeling that I felt when I
originally had them
so when I first got this when I was
still in high school I had absolutely no
idea what I was doing with my life I
mean does anybody ever actually really
know what they're doing with their life
but in high school you never really know
and things are always extremely
confusing so this thing for me
represented a time of extreme confusion
the three GS on the other hand I kind of
already knew what I was doing I was
still making youtube videos in 2009 and
I was still pretty well established
don't get me wrong not that well
established because I'm pretty sure I
was basically homeless in Los Angeles I
was bouncing back and forth between San
Francisco and LA not really sure where
my place was I knew that I was on the
right track and it was something that I
wanted to keep pursuing and I did
because I'm still here today still doing
it guess what yeah 2017 iJustine it yes
she's still alive but I will say that as
you do go through life not knowing what
you're doing it can sometimes be a gift
because I feel like if I had a plan
especially in high school or even in
college I might not be doing what I'm
doing today because a lot of people told
me that what I was doing was crazy or
stupid or silly and I should probably
get a real job and I'll tell you what I
work way harder at my not-real job than
I ever did working for somebody else at
a real job I've said it before we're
making YouTube videos especially for me
because I still shoot edit a lot of
stuff myself it's a lot of work it's a
lot of time and right now I'm probably
gonna stay up all night and edit this
video so I can post it tomorrow morning
for you guys it is something that I
truly love and I'm seriously honestly so
passionate about technology and
everything that surrounds it I'm pretty
sure that that's something that I've
always known judging by my senior
picture that I took with my Apple
Computer that's one thing that I will
say that I've always stuck with is the
things that I'm passionate about I
somehow managed to work that into a
career and make that a part of my daily
life video games technology traveling
creating fun content making people laugh
hopefully making some people laugh it's
now something that I get to do a lot and
very often and I could not choose a
better job so it might be a little
cheesy and a little sentimental but I do
have Apple to thank for a lot of that
Steve Jobs gave me that inspiration at a
super young age I think I was in sixth
grade when I read my first book about
Steve Jobs and Steve Jobs as a person
and how he treated people some
might not be the best but the thing that
I looked up most to for Steve and the
words that stuck with me from a very
young age was think different because I
already was thinking differently and I
felt bad about it and I felt like I
should be doing what everybody else was
doing but from that sixth grade age of
doing a book report on Steve Jobs and
nobody else having any idea who he was
at that point and just thought it was
some crazy computer girl and at that
young age Steve I will never forget the
way that you changed my life the way
that you have changed many many others
and a happy belated birthday to the one
the only Steve Jobs we wish that you
were still here with us today because I
would love to see the way that you would
be pushing Apple and what direction and
what would be happening right now
because I feel like the whole landscape
of everything could potentially be
different but Steve was still here okay
that was a lot of rambling but I'll see
you guys later
thanks for listening and don't be afraid
to go after something that you're
passionate about because it's your life
you can't essentially do what you want
and even after this crazy story that I
just told you I don't want you to think
that any of this was easy because my
goodness it wasn't it's been a long
freakin road of ups and downs and
successes and many many failures you
just don't quit that's the real secret
so if you don't quit
I mean that's like eventually it's gonna
work out
[Music]